every one of you is a media company
first and then you are who you are that
is a big change from the history of
business what I'm concerned about is
that there's a lot of people here who
see or hear what I'm saying but don't
want to make video content they're
insecure how they look they're not
comfortable in it and I want you to hear
something from somebody who probably
benefited from the growth of internet
video as much as anyone has over the
last 15 years it is not a requirement to
be a media company let me give you a
very detailed Insight that nobody's
taking advantage of if someone's in the
mood to go test for the next 30 days at
this point in my career there's enough
stuff that I put out of the internet and
I'm quite consistent that I think the
biggest value I can bring is actually
let you go into the details of your
questions under the macro and get into
the micro but to just set it up for the
individuals here who may be a little
less familiar um let me start with this
I'm writing a new book I'm about to
finish it it's a follow thank you um
it's a follow up from a book that I
wrote 10 years ago that is outside of
crush it my first book the book that I
most get emails and DMS about saying
thank you or this impacted me and that
was a book called jab jab jab right hook
and that book mattered for a lot of
people because I wrote it at a time when
people weren't realizing that content in
social media more so than anything else
was about to become the Battleground the
battleground of growth popularity
opportunity and that book was really fun
to write at the time and I think we're
in that same moment again now so
originally I was going to call it jab
jab jab left hook um but I've decided to
call it uh day trading attention and I
really want to talk about day trading
attention I'm thrilled to get into a lot
of things that run through my mind both
culturally and content-wise here with
all of you today I started my career of
making content first it was wine and
then it was very tactical internet
marketing and like what was going on and
as some of you may know it's really
evolved now to a much higher plane of
perspective because I went four or five
years telling people exactly what to do
on Twitter or Facebook or Tumblr at the
time or YouTube and I just would watch
event an event an event like this
consistently all the content I was
putting out I would just see so many
people not do it and that's what got me
to the next plane of what I think about
and spend time on now which is why are
people not doing that and it got me into
the concepts of insecurity and
confidence and patience and all the
stuff that I really am quite passionate
about how do you balance here's a big
one for this crew probably across the
board how do you balance hunger and
tenacity and ambition with
patience how many people here consume
some of my content have a sense of me
just raise your hands thank you the
thing that I most the reason I wanted to
see that was to go where I'm about to go
as a lot of you know I push patient
heavy and most people struggle with it
cuz they hear I say patience and you all
hear
complacency ambition and patience
balanced perfectly is sustainable
happiness and
success ambition grounded in the need to
happen quickly because you're insecure
and you want to show everybody you made
it is a [__] death
trap and so that's why I got into to
patience but before I get into the
mindset stuff and some of the stuff that
I'm really thinking about to give you
any chance of success sustained in long
term I am going to go a little bit
tactical and in the
weeds the one thing that 100% connects
every single person in this room is
regardless of what you do real estate
mortgages uh any other entrepreneurial
venture thinking about starting starting
a side hustle doing videography being an
agency whatever it might be the only
thing that I can guarante talk about
right now that will hit every person
which is why I want to talk about it is
that every one of you is a media company
first and then you are who you are
everybody in this room if you do you
know housewear if you sell sneakers if
you're a lawyer if you're a tax
accountant everybody here the second
they understand how serious I am about
what I'm saying
here everyone here is a media company
come
what you do for a living and that is a
big change from the history of business
and
so what I'm concerned about is that
there's a lot of people here who see or
hear what I'm saying but don't want to
make video content they're insecure how
they look they're not comfortable in it
and I want you to hear something from
somebody who probably benefited from the
growth of internet video as much as
anyone has over the last 15 years it is
not a requirement to be a media company
let me explain let me give you a very
detailed Insight that nobody's taking
advantage of just if someone's in the
mood to go test for the next 30 days
Instagram super
visual if you are a remarkable writer
here actually you know what let me do
this real quick before I even say this
I'm going to ask all of you the gift of
talking the ability to do video and the
ability to write I me ask all of you to
think right now if I asked you what
you're best at talking so you can do
audio like a podcast video which
obviously has a component of talking but
also is a video it's a different dynamic
or writing out of those three to
communicate to make the thing that you
want to happen in your world I'm going
to ask everybody right now to raise
their hand for what they do best if you
were best at writing of those three
please raise your hands high raise them
high thank you
audio no video involved but just talking
raise them high I see some [__]
hands sir in the back there that's a
little low a little higher there you go
my man big
number
video perfect if you looked little less
Unwritten right and the other two audio
and video kind of a 50/50 must have been
6040 I need everybody to hear this the
only thing I've done well in my
professional career is I had
self-awareness
and I executed against my
self-awareness the only thing I was good
at always was not try to be anybody but
I that I wasn't not trying to appease
anyone it showed up bad early on because
I was such a bad student and I got D's
and Fs and it seemingly looked like a
weakness but even at 10 11 12 years old
I had such conviction of who I was going
to be that I genuinely understood that
that framework of learning wasn't
working for me and I needed to do it a
different way so I need everybody to
hear this there is a direct correlation
of how much you're going to grow if
you're in the interest of growing and
I'm going to assume if you're here on a
Friday afternoon like there's nobody who
should be here if they're not interested
in growing so I'm just going to make a
blank assumption everyone here is
looking to do something with themselves
there's a direct
correlation on how successful you will
be based on how good you are at making
content for the internet period And by
the way I want everyone to hear this
millions of people will build successful
businesses without proding content for
the internet you can build a great
reputation behind the you can do it but
there's a direct correlation of how big
your upside can be based on how good you
are at producing content for the
internet the thing that no one's telling
you is it doesn't have to be
video it doesn't have to be video you
don't have to be overthe top and
ridiculous like I I'm so sad that I'm so
high energy I wish a lot of times that I
wasn't cuz it still would have happened
for me I didn't get here here because
I'm a hyper Jersey boy I got here
because I understood distribution and I
only talk about [__] I know the reason I
started a wine show first when I saw
this was because it was the thing I most
knew I almost did a New York Jets show
too but like that was the other thing
that I debated besides the wine show if
the people in this room can understand
that the people that win on the internet
making content do not have to be experts
think about all of you in your business
and your craft right now where you know
people are growing online but don't
actually have as much depth of knowledge
in the craft that you have you don't
have to position yourself as an expert
it's the biggest mistake that people
make the two biggest mistakes that
people make is one they think it's only
video without realizing that the people
that raise their hand for written word
or audio can win just as much Malcolm
Gladwell does not have a daily Tik Tock
he wins because he writes there's plenty
of podcasters less now because
everybody's filming themselves do the
podcast they figured it out but there's
plenty of podcasters who still don't
crush a daily Instagram Tik Tok Twitter
Youtube shorts
framework the two biggest mistakes
people make is they think there's only
one way to do content online when
written word right now is the fastest
merging what's going on on LinkedIn or
back to the way I got to this point
earlier here's the hack on Instagram you
can literally take a picture of anything
it would be nice that it makes sense to
what you're talking about but if you
then write three meaningful paragraphs
with that photo you would be stunned how
much you can grow and win on Instagram
it is far less a visual only platform
and on the flip side because there's
some good-look [__] people in this
room right now so I'm making some
assumption that you're hitting the gram
pretty
hard the other mistake is the reverse
too many people are just relying on the
video and the photo and they're mailing
in the cre the copy and the copy is an
enormous variable of the success on
Instagram the two biggest mistakes that
people make are they don't realize that
any one of the three mediums that I made
you raise your hands about are all
viable and two they don't focus on
talking about [__] they actually know
they posture and front to be an expert
in something before they are without
realizing that if they were just
authentic and said this is my journey to
becoming knowledgeable in real estate
this is my journey in becoming
knowledgeable in DTC this is my journey
into being knowledgeable into fashion or
even better if you want to be fullprof
don't say you're an expert say you're an
Enthusiast people's insecurity of trying
to position themselves as an expert when
they know they're not fully there is
hurting them tremendously with growth
opportunity so day training attention is
a very basic game of
how do you not waste
money and how do you take any money you
actually spend on building your business
and extract the most value let me
explain how many people here have done
influencer marketing you've paid an
influencer to do something for your
business raise your hands high I just
want to get a sense all right enough for
me to go with it let's talk about
influencer marketing today as we sit
here today October
20123 influencer marketing is one of the
places where you most can get a
remarkable deal for your th000 or 5,000
or $50,000 or could get completely
ripped off for your thousand 5,000
$50,000 the swings of it working are
extreme it means you actually have to
know the craft it means you have to be
not tricked by just following count it
needs means that you have to know what
engagement really means is engagement
they're just going to consume it or is
engagement mean they're going to convert
most people are using influencer
marketing the wrong way because they're
only looking for it to sell the thing
right away instead of building the brand
most of us bought the clothes we're
wearing right now not because they
cookied us and followed us around the
internet and made us buy it or they
knocked on our door and sold it it's
because you wanted it because it was
built on
brand too many people in a room like
this think so short-term transactional
in every single aspect of how they're
building their thing that it leaves them
to not be able to grow into the full
brand because they're constantly in
sales mode instead of marketing and
branding mode there's a direct conflict
between selling and marketing and all
that selling is is someone who can't
Market let me say that again nice and
slow and by the way I'm a Salesman I
love selling
[__] but for everyone in this room if
you want to go to that next place
understanding how to be in branding and
marketing which actually is you know
back to like my journey is quite
enjoyable when you're like you don't
have the stress of every interaction
being something that you need to create
an
outcome so there's a lot of people here
who could be bringing a lot more value
to their Audience by actually educating
you know when I let me just use real
estate agents how many people are real
estate
agents so real estate agents I'm telling
you much more content about the towns
that you sell in much more like go
interview the principal of the high
school and put that on your social media
for all the people that are considering
to move and really care about the school
system go interview the entrepreneur
who's had a 50 years's family restaurant
business in town like be the mayor or
the newspaper of your town with your
social because if every single post
coming out of your mouth is this open
house and buy this you're going to lose
the audience you can't close on every
breath and the fact that social media is
free it's free I don't know if anybody
here has done other marketing besides
organic posting on social media but you
can't go buy a full page ad and a
newspaper for free you can't run a
commercial on TV for free the for the
real estate agents like the Billboards
and the bench ads at the bus stop not
free everything else costs money and
social media is the one play of course
you can run ads on social but social
media is the one place that every person
in this room especially the way it's
going now with the tiktock ification of
social media that the fact that every
single person now can post one post on
Tik Tok and get hundreds of thousands of
people to see it based on the Merit of
the content that is bananas and let me
go back to that because I think a lot of
people don't know what's happening right
now hence why I've decided to write the
book
again the social media that I got into
and for a history lesson it worked out
real well for me I was an early investor
in Facebook and Twitter in
2006 that social media I grew up with
was more like email marketing how many
people here have done email email
marketing in their career raise your
hands social was email marketing you
would try to get followers you would
posted and a percentage of those
followers would see it right that's why
I understood it I crushed email
marketing in the mid 90s late 90s social
meet sense to me get a th000 followers
30 or 40% of them will see it good let
me keep building the social media we all
find ourselves in right this second is
not based on the social graph not based
us following each other and you get a
chance of seeing it's now based on the
interest graph it's based on what are we
into and so this is what's happening
with the
algorithms what does this mean to
everyone here there are people in this
room who've not spent one day trying to
be good at Social when it's the most
important thing to their business and
tomorrow unlike the last 15 years I've
been on stages like this where I'd be
like [__] you know if we get into Q&A
and you're like Gary you know honestly
you insired me I'm going to get serious
about social now like what should I do
my brain be like [__] you got like six
years before this gets
good the fact that if somebody raises
their hand in this room and asks that
same question to me right now and I know
if they happen to be talented or if they
listen to me carefully and get educated
on how to be good at it and all that
information's free on the internet you
don't even have to buy a [__] Manan $16
book that their second or third post
could get a million views and start the
process of changing their business that
is like insane to me and I continue to
stand on my own two feet every single
day and I baffled by the collective
inaction by entrepreneurs and
individuals on this opportunity this is
arguably the greatest opportunity for
the individual since the birth of the
United States of America it is literally
free
distribution and people aren't doing
anything about it and so so I highly
compel you to stop thinking about
social actually let me put it this way I
I have a personal brand I'm a media
company and I have to do stuff I have 29
full-time employees on my
content going to say it again I went for
big impact with the silence
there I I just really need everyone to
hear this because there's a lot of
people growing here there's a lot of
people winning here there's a lot of
people starting their Journey here I I
don't really know I'm just really trying
to ground you in real [__] I'm going to
say it nice and slow one more time I
have
29 full-time employees on just my
content in my 2000 person Vayner media
agency because that's how important this
is and by the way more and more of them
are now all over the world because with
AI you're going to see me speaking every
language in the
world converting all my content because
I'm trying to win everywhere I'm trying
to win with 8 billion people I want to
be as big in Johannesburg as I want to
be in Dallas I want to be as big in
Saudi Arabia as I want to be in
Cincinnati and so I've you know I I just
can't comprehend being in this room on a
Friday afternoon which means you're
ambitious and going for it in October
2023 and all of you continue to [__]
not put in the work in the one place
that has the disproportionate impact on
your business and good news I didn't
invent these platforms I have no emotion
in platform I'm going to leave in an
hour and could give a [__] if you
actually do it but I need you to hear
me I need you to hear me this is the
best opportunity to get you think you're
too late I know what you're thinking I I
get a 100,000 DMS a
day I know what you're thinking I read
that [__] I read an hour's worth on the
flight from New York to here right now
Gary it's too late I'm 30 my life's over
you
know you know I didn't listen to you
five years ago on Tik Tok I I missed it
you didn't miss
anything all that is is you using
excuses to not put in the work there's a
lot of people how many people here would
consider themselves in good physical
shape raise your
hands for the people that just raised
their hands have you been in a position
within the last 10 years not nitpicking
cuz you're a beast but I mean like no
you were like me like 10 years ago I was
a piece of crap now I'm decentish as you
know cuz he filmed the guy that worked
me out every single day at 6: a.m. how
many people here who just raised their
hand and said that they're in good solid
physical health were at some point in
the last 10 years completely not there
raise your hands all right actually can
you all stand up can you stand up don't
[__] me stand up I want everybody to
visualize this please don't get lazy I
saw some of you raise your hand and
you're not standing get up if if you
feel
this I just want everybody to look at
this cuz this is going to land it look
around there was thank you you can all
sit there was no
shortcut I mean unless you got real bank
and you [__] did the whole plastic
surgery
thing it was
work there was no shortcut I have
unlimited people in the fitness space
that asked me for business advice and
the only thing they're asking me for is
the shortcut in physical health land
they realiz all that [__] apple and
and [__] apple vinegar pills and all
the hor they know that's all [__]
the work is eat properly [__] do your
exercise routine properly especially if
you want muscle like do the exercise
properly put the protein it's [__]
basic I could sit here and tell every
person that doesn't feel good about
their health exactly what to do on a 101
education of it the problem is it's
hard I'm not saying anything profound
I'm telling you that you need to post
three 3 4 7 12 19 times a day on social
media and that you will double triple
cud dble your
business I just think most of you don't
want to take money out of your pocket
and hire someone to help you do it you'd
rather take that money and buy some dumb
[__] and so that's how I see the world
and I think it's an enormous opportunity
right now especially because I would be
on stages like this for the last decade
and there was a little bit of you're a
little behind because it was email
marketing you haven't started yet I have
7 million followers I am ahead the fact
that I'm not ahead of anybody in this
room right now besides brand and being
known we are all now in an incredible
era of social media where the content
itself the single post every time is
your variable not how many followers you
have that's
crazy so I'm going to say it one more
time just to put a bow on it because if
I'm anyone in this room and I haven't
been thinking about this right this
should be the single biggest encourager
the fact that everyone on every day at
some level which is not fully true
because Fame and awareness does matter
but the fact that every day people that
have never ever gone viral ever been
consistent have 12 followers every day
on Tik Tok right now specifically more
though Instagram and Facebook and
YouTube shorts are starting to act this
way more and more every day that people
are posting their first video about real
estate or have you thought about this
mortgage thing or have you thought about
you know soup or clean eating or
whatever the hell you're
into are are having a single video pop
them off and start their process it's
incredibly exciting and I will say
something else it will not last forever
these things have been flow and so I I
highly encourage you to understand how
big the opportunity of day trading
attention
is how serious it is to figure out
yourself
and say okay look I'm insecure I don't
want to be on camera I don't want people
to talk about how I look I got you
that's a whole different game and a
different work stream but that shouldn't
stop you tomorrow from taking your
iPhone hitting the record button on
audio and spitting your knowledge for
six minutes and then just posting the
audio on LinkedIn or Facebook or
Instagram do we have that understood
cool thank you let's clap that up
because I need some
energy
before I go into Q&A and then please
when we go into Q&A any for the people
that raised your hands you want to ask
me about anything like Tik Tok stuff
running your agency running a team the
New York Jets what they're going to do
against the Broncos this weekend
whatever you need I'm here for it so
think about where you want to go um the
other thing I want to talk about is very
near and dear to my heart how many
people here have more than five
employees raise your hand raise it high
just just to get a sense okay I'll go
there then thank you for the people in
here that raised their hand with five or
more employees there's a couple things
I'd like to talk about which is
predominantly under the bucket of
culture um I'm surprised by how many
people think it's interesting or cool or
different when I talk about the stuff I
talk about around kindness or empathy or
things of that nature but I'm not
surprised because I'm 47 and I grew up
in Jersey and I know that like everyone
thinks like nice guys finish last and
like you've got to be a gangster to win
and it's a ruthless world and sharp
elbows and all that stuff I would just
highly encourage the people that just
raised their hands to really realize how
ridiculous of a concept nice guys
finishing last is and that in real life
of business especially where we are now
where employees have more and more
options including just doing their own
side Hustle
culture really matters and and I highly
recommend people look themselves in the
mirror tonight and ask themselves are
they like the 80% or even 90% And do
they run their teams with fear like if
you threaten to fire someone with an
aggressive
voice you're losing and I let me explain
why and just I know a lot of people in
this room don't fully know me I'm not
foofy foofy by guy I'm not your
grandma the stuff I'm talking about is
actually how you make more
money I'm I'm not looking to over coddle
gen Z that's not where I'm going with
this I think one of the biggest issues
literally in America is eighth place
Trophies the reason everyone's so
insecure is we tell these kids when
they're little losing is bad I promise
you the only reason I'm on this stage
age is because of my relationship with
losing I love losing it's so sick I like
it more than winning we have to get
people prepared for losing you give
eighth place trophies you're demonizing
losing and then these kids go into the
wild and life is different mommy and
daddy aren't there to yell at the
teachers so how many people have parents
in here raise your hands I think we can
all understand the coddling is what
leads to the issues right and so I
highly recommend taking a step back and
understanding that and that's how I
think about
work at work I'm not talking about
creating entitlement but I am talking
about that in America and most of the
rest of the world the rules at work are
all [__] up when I got into the agency
game like our dude was saying earlier
for the last 15 years I didn't realize
how many people cried at
work if you have employees crying at
your job you are losing you've got the
wrong game I'm telling you you have the
wrong
game and what's happening that I don't
think people see is as the internet and
as Ai and all these things start to pop
up people have more
options when everyone's like jenz is so
[__] soft and entitled or they're
smart would you rather go work for $11
an hour doing something you [__] hate
or would you rather make 50,000 a year
in social media ads making videos doing
the [__] you love
we need to be careful about our
judgment this is not about entitlement
this is about options and there's a lot
of entrepreneurs and Leaders with
employees who are not understanding the
enormous hidden value of building a nice
culture and what most leaders struggle
with because most people are actually
not all that bad it's when there's
pressure they're the worst version of
themselves when I really and and I just
said that I watched a lot of people body
language to me like yeah this is the one
leaders this is the one one more time
five or more
employees my friends please I'm telling
you this is the one when something is
[__] up when an
employee is directly attributable to you
losing Revenue that's when you need to
be nicer to them not the reverse and
that's not how we were taught and that's
not how the game was built and that is
absolutely one of the other biggest
opportunities the two biggest
opportunities for growth in this full
room regardless of where you're at is
content and
culture content is hard because it's
hard work it's like the gym and culture
is hard because it doesn't land
natural people just don't think it's
right like they they they hear me they
want to be but it feels delusional it
feels
ideological but it's remarkably
achievable
and I just think that you're taking
employees for granted I mean it and I
think you think they don't have another
option and because the last 13 times you
said you're sorry and it was okay that
the 14th time it will be too but I
promise you especially and I know how
business how many of the people with
five employees or less excuse me or more
also don't have 100 employees you're
between five and 99 raise your hands
especially For This
Crew
at that level a lot of times you're way
more vulnerable based on one or two of
your employees than you want to
think actually let's all CL that crew
just sit for a second with me because I
I feel that I appreciate the energy back
on that in your mind like really just
think for a second if your top two
people that really right if they're gone
tomorrow
what so please live that life
a run a good business and always have a
backup I literally have a backup for a
backup of a backup of every important
person in my company not because I'm
going to run a bad culture but people
grow and they want to do something else
or God forbid like you get older sad
[__] happens right people get sick
people have something horrible happen I
I mean it's this is devastating for me a
super top employee of mine actually
ironically I think yeah I think it's the
story is grounded in Dallas a major
employee of mine for last 6 years
cruising perfect her single best friend
in the world they're both in their 40s
just passed away from cancer and she's
super shook she doesn't have a family of
her own and she's taking time off to
take care of that woman's
baby I just come in on Monday morning
that person's
gone thank God for me and thank God for
her cuz I'm treating her incredibly well
I've got the backup of the backup of the
backup up so we could absorb it but a
lot of you don't even have a backup for
one employee right now that you can put
in your
mind and more importantly I get that
because you don't have unlimited money
to hire everybody but I don't understand
why you don't treat everyone like
family that I will never understand you
are not better then because it's your
business if you're a leader you work for
them they don't work for
you it's true brother thank you and
honestly if you're acting the reverse of
what I'm talking about I'm just going to
give you an inside secret that you may
not
know all that means is you're deeply
insecure and all that means is you're
tricking the 95% of losers but the 5% of
winners see
you so I highly recommend you have that
talk with
[Music]
yourself